the question that i keep pondering of
what i see is working and not working is
do you know yourself if making videos
doesn't come as easy as drinking oxygen
you have friction you're insecure about
the way you look you're insecure about
what you got to say i get comments left
and right garyvee you say the same [ __ ]
and i'm like that's right [ __ ]
because i believe it
very humbled thank you
all right let's get into it let's break
it into macro and micro because when i
think about the hypothesis of what we're
trying to accomplish here the way to
actually pull it off in my perspective
is macro and micro what do i mean by
that macro is really just mindset and
perspective like you're not going to do
the things that i i'm going to talk
about in the micro if you're not in the
right place on the macro let me give you
an example in the macro
a stunning majority of people in here
are not unlocking the full max potential
predicated on a lack of self-awareness
you'd like to be something
but you're actually not that
and what i mean by that is when i think
about video
there's
all of us i mean when i look at my
keynotes that i'm about to do i'm like
oh that's affected by macho man randy
savage that's affected by richard pryor
and chris rock like i can see like the
things that i watched as a kid impact
the way i talk
the reason i bring that up is
i really think that self-awareness is
one of the most significant aspects in
winning in video
i think a lot of people are trying to do
certain things that are just not there
not that you can't build those skills
but i'm a very big fan of eliminating
friction i mean the amount of people
that i've watched in the last 15 years
try to do me when when they would crush
by doing them
i bring it up all the time like i'm a
high energy over the top like very
jerseyed out super like like i'm just in
minnesota for 400 hours standing taking
selfies fly to vegas do three talks like
that's a different kind of breed
not that that's good bad or indifferent
i actually
am trying to talk more about like
i don't view that as like better i just
view it as i'm very good at being me i'm
really good at being me like the only
thing i think i actually do special is
be me
and i think when i think about how are
you gonna win
in this play you've got to really be you
even when it doesn't seem that you works
for example for a lot of the youngsters
in here and definitely for people over
40 this is gonna resonate when i hit the
scene on video and and keynotes
i did not dress the part i cursed crazy
everybody told me i was going to lose i
couldn't win it
and it happened like a lot of places
wouldn't book me because i cursed too
much i didn't wear a suit which was like
[ __ ] completely unacceptable 15 years
ago and like people like what are you
doing and i'm like i just don't have the
ability not to be me
and i was willing to leave money on the
table
accolades
everything i was willing to leave
everything on the table because i just
did not know how to not be me so as you
sit here today there's tactics there's
things there's people you admire you
wish you were
i wish i could read
i'm being dead serious i wish i could
read i have no reading comprehension
i have to waste my time on five minute
calls all day long because i can't read
an email for 13 seconds
i wish i could read
but i can't so i have a different style
and that's how i think about video it is
very
when musically hit
and i knew it was going to go
obviously tick-tock bought it and became
one the same
everybody
around me was like but you don't dance
and i was like that's for damn [ __ ]
sure
because by the way if i dance you'd see
it by now
i was like i'm not going to dance like
14 year old teenagers on tick tock i'm
going to put out my content i'm going to
know that 14 year olds are listening so
the adjective might be different the
reference might be different the context
will be different
video in my opinion today
is a battleground of a quadrant that
looks kind of like this you need to
communicate the way you communicate
there are people that are not dynamic
they're monotone and they do just fine
and dominate
they are and so if you're a monotone
person then that's that
right
two
you have to know the context of where
you're making the content
we're talking backstage i argue that the
place that i'm the least good at that is
youtube ironically youtube's the one
platform where i don't do best practices
i suck at thumbnails i don't do breaks
mr beast makes fun of me every week
just text me you
suck
i'm like you're right because it's the
one that i don't do it's the one that i
don't do i do all the rest of them so
it's always contextual
but
what i really think is that
when you go into the macro place you've
got such an easy
easier game to do the micro the micro is
very obvious to me it's tactics
right the tactics are clear to me
but most people don't execute on it
because they don't have the first part
down
right if you don't know yourself
and you don't have a grasp on that you
have no prayer on tick tock and nobody
nobody should be confused in this room
the biggest arbitrage in attention in
society is tick tock
right this second you want a tactic
there's no debate there's nothing close
if you are not fully pot committed
into taking the opportunity on tick tock
you're missing the biggest opportunity
since facebook fan pages in 2012.
instagram hasn't been this good since
2011.
and a lot of you know
how many people here put out content on
instagram raise your hands raise them
high
how many people by show of hands raising
them feel that it was going better 24
months ago
you know so like the reality is is that
the supply and demand of attention moves
on these platforms
the tick tock arbitrage is going to
close and it's going to close the next
24 months and the land grab is right now
the only thing i give a [ __ ] about for
you to win out of this whole talk is
that you go back home and make three or
four tick tucks a day
i'd like you to be good at them
so i'll continue to talk otherwise i
could leave right now
but that game is about the context of
knowing how to make a tick tock
which is very easy because you can just
google how to make good tick tocks and
there's unlimited tick tock content and
how to make good ducks that's there the
question that i keep pondering of what i
see is working and not working is do you
know yourself
right like people like your like if it
doesn't come as easy as breathing oxygen
you need to understand why
if making videos doesn't come as easy as
drinking oxygen you have friction you
don't you're insecure about the way you
look
you're insecure about what you got to
say
huge problem in this space when i
analyze it people talk about [ __ ] they
don't know
yeah
like if you know somebody you know
occasionally
if i'm on a real roll of talking about
the same [ __ ] for a while
i get comments left and right
for a period of time where they're like
gary v you say the same [ __ ] and i'm
like that's right [ __ ]
because i believe it
because it's the thing to say
you know this
some of you have been affected by other
people by myself you've affected people
you sometimes say the same thing
somebody's heard it 87 times i said the
same [ __ ] to my father this week here at
bcon that i've been saying for 37 years
and he told me this time it clicked
the amount of people
watch this you want to see something
cool by show hands doesn't hurt my
feelings i'm detached from my success
and from people [ __ ] on me by show
of hands how many people here the first
time they ever saw me thought i sucked
them with a scam artist a piece of [ __ ]
raise your hands raise them high higher
higher higher
right like and and then how many people
that just raised their hands
were affected possibly by a piece of
content in their lives
that's it that's the game
got it that's the game
the reason that was an interesting thing
and i hope people look back and saw how
many hands went up if you can go from
this guy's a piece of [ __ ] scam artist
to this person positively affected me
that is only required and can only be
achievable when you only talk about
things you know and you're willing to
say them 87 000 different ways
most people get caught up because they
feel like they've already said their
thing and they just start making up some
other [ __ ]
right
i see people like yo i'm a real estate
expert i'm like six months later i'm
like i'm a crypto expert like 13 months
later i'm the king of cannabis i'm like
this [ __ ] person
you want to win in video two very
hardcore truths one you have to know who
you are as a communicator and not try to
push yourself to be some other
communicator
some of you are funny
get funnier
some of you are clever with words feel
comfortable some are loud as [ __ ] like
me
do you understand how real of a
businessman i am and how many people
think i'm a motivational speaker
do you know how underestimated i am for
my professional career that
people have no concept of how many big
businesses i've built and what i do for
a living because my style of
communication feels spilly
and i'm willing to walk around on earth
underestimated because i have no
interest in slightly tweaking down my
energy because that's just not who i am
and it doesn't matter what people think
the truth is the truth if you are not
gift of gab but you can like what about
making videos where you just read
it might not be as compelling as i died
but that's you
some of you shouldn't make video at all
you should leave right the [ __ ] now
i'm being dead serious some of you
should be writing because you're a
remarkable writer
and you're forcing yourself to believe
that video is the only winning because
you can see it yet tons of people are
winning writing
some of you should take a beautiful
photo and just write
some of you should just make a video of
something mundane that makes the point
of your video it's literally a video of
a banana and you're talking about
slippery slopes
you like that one
i think it's a good one
it's good because this game is
completely based on you being
comfortable in the way you make
and talking about [ __ ] you know
and most people are doing neither
thank you
that is really the macro
the micro simple the micro simple i'll
tell you why because no matter what
platform you're making on best practices
exist
right like if you want to be better at
it like youtube and tick tock have
unlimited content of best practices for
youtube and tick tock scattered all over
this is not an education thing that's
that's 13 hours of work and then you
know thumbnails do this
break on your youtube videos every three
four minutes like i do none of that on
youtube but everywhere else i do it
like you can figure that part out
youtube shorts is a huge arbitrage
everyone's chasing tic toc so anything
that a new platform launches
is always going to over index
there's no reason to not make a reels
over a regular post because they're
gonna big the outcome of the
distribution it's all there that's
[ __ ] simple [ __ ]
this that's the simple [ __ ] there
wouldn't be a need for this or me or
sure anything else if that was the game
that is not the game
everybody wants to make it the game
because it's tangible
it's just not the game the game is are
you comfortable in how you make
do you have a process to make
a lot of you
for example
if you think when i think about my
career i very quickly was like oh my god
this youtube thing
in december of 2005 i was like this
thing's gonna change the world
because in 2002 i wanted to make wine
videos but i found out how expensive it
was to host videos on the internet it
was like a trillion dollars a video it
was oh gee this is why web 3 comes so
natural to me that everyone's like
scamming and this and i'm like
technology will catch up
just give it a few minutes
but
so when youtube came out i'm like oh i
can finally make these videos like when
my developer told me like i don't pay
anything right he's like no like i asked
him like 14 more times like but i don't
pay right he's like no i was like let's
make videos so
but it was funny
what i decided to make i saw a lot of
opportunity i was already a businessman
i want like i had those thoughts but i
was like the thing i know the best at
this point in my life is wine
so let me make wine videos and let me
make them my way and it's fun for me to
think back that the advice i'm giving
right now in 2022 is exactly what i
lived
16 years ago when i first entered the
arena
i'm telling you a lot of you are making
videos around genres where you think
there's money
versus making videos around the stuff
you like and know which will then lead
to the money
thank you mate i really really believe
that i think a lot more of you should be
making very niche content around stuff
you have passion around because then you
will have the everyone's like how do you
get so much energy i'm like i love this
[ __ ]
i don't wanna [ __ ] golf
i'm not interested in [ __ ] skiing
i don't wanna [ __ ]
sail don't want to cook
i want to be an entrepreneur
i want to make content
but if you're making content around
something that you heard has good
adsense or there's good brand deals in
or that's where the money is you're
[ __ ] finished
because it's not you
and if you try to make content like me
who like clearly got so lucky that he
grew up in the 80s because if they put
me into the 2000 system they would have
drug the [ __ ] out of me
[Laughter]
so
i mean luckily i'm the best mom she
would be like [ __ ] you but
you need to [ __ ] really lean into who
you are as a communicator
i you know it was a funny thing to say
but i do think some of you need to not
make video for example i think a lot of
people
are genuinely this is how you were
raised this is your circumstance you're
really insecure about the way you look
it's devastating i don't like it i wish
people didn't but it's like more energy
goes into how you look on camera than
the content
maybe you should be an audio podcaster
only with no video maybe
because anything that's stopping you
from the message is a problem
and one of the things that stops from
message back to ping pong to the other
thing is talking about stuff you don't
know
everyone's like why do you why are you
so good at this like why is it so easy
like i jump in the pod i just did a
podcast and doing this they're like why
do you improv everything why is it like
this why don't you want to know anything
i'm like because i know what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about
if you're studying to make content
you lost
if you think you're a [ __ ] expert
yeah
there's a lot of quiet giggling on that
one
this what i've just talked about is the
most significant part of making video
thumbnails this
hack that
math this analytics this
means dog [ __ ] if you don't have the
thing i've just been talking about down
my great hope is that a lot of you go
back home and start making content about
different [ __ ] all together because it's
the thing you either love the most which
means you'll do the research and be in
it or the thing you know the most and if
you're lucky like i am and the thing you
love the most is the thing you know the
most then it can get really crazy
but that
is my observation
15 years into this game who's winning
the people leaning all in to them
who are they how do they roll
let the world catch up to you stop
chasing the world
[Applause]
you understand oh crypto i'm going to go
there no no
let the world catch up to you all this
collectible garage sale sports car they
caught up to me
i was a dork for liking that [ __ ] my
friends were like you're going garage
sailing you know like you like flipping
[ __ ] this is stupid in the 90s
college
i mean that was the only option
entrepreneurship a non-conversation in
the 80s and 90s college was the only way
you were gonna win
that's not the conversation today
twitter social media people sh there's
nothing i've ever done in my life that
the majority of the people every good
thing that has happened to me starts
with everybody [ __ ] on me
1996 i'm gonna sell wine on the internet
everyone who's gonna buy wine on the
internet i said everybody
that sounded crazy how many people over
45 in this room raise your hand remember
how crazy that was back then that [ __ ]
was crazy
2006 twitter
i was like twitter twitter twitter
twitter everyone's like this is the
stupidest [ __ ] thing i've ever heard
in my life you're telling me that people
are gonna
post things that they're going to the
post office walking the dog eating a
pizza who gives a [ __ ] about that
i answered
everybody
nfts blockchain or owning digital assets
people struggling with that there's not
a person in this room that's not going
to have nfts in 10 years not because
it's a collectible because it's a
utility you're not going to be able to
take a flight on a plane
because the nft is going to be the
ticket the [ __ ] a qr code
please listen to me
let the world catch up to you
this whole narrative about being kind as
a gangster businessman was [ __ ]
laughed at 15 years ago now people are
starting to get
it you might like legos you might like
pancakes
you might like talking about parenting
or being poorly parented
therapy meditation i don't [ __ ] know
but i know every person in this room has
something they like
most people don't do it around what they
like because they don't think there's
money in it
gary there's no money in hot wheels yes
there is
get 150 000 people a day watching your
podcast on hot wheels and mattel will
write you a six figure check
people are scared to be themselves
people are scared to be themselves
when being yourself
is the only moat
in
life if you leave here because all the
information around the micro i don't
even get into it you know why it doesn't
[ __ ] matter it's so easy
you can google that [ __ ] right now
unlimited free unlimited free tactics
this
what do you make
how do you make it
do you like it
that's the [ __ ] game and so
i won't preach this in perpetuity
because it is so crystal clear you can't
sustain
doing something you don't like
especially if you're doing it for money
you will lose that game every day of the
week
so i hope you take a step back from this
talk i hope you realize
don't be disappointed
in how you communicate embrace how you
communicate
linkedin
has much arbitrage as tick-tock
right right
right
just talk about [ __ ] you like and know
it's as simple as that and i know most
of you aren't
i know it
and i don't want that for you
because that becomes a hamster wheel and
that's why it hasn't happened
and i'd really prefer it to happen for
you
i'd like you to win
thank you
[Music]
you